we've got a big announcement to make
where do you want to make the
announcement or no no IIIi I don't want
to I don't want to make the announcement
all right okay I'll do it everybody Rick
and Morty is back brand-new season four
in November 2019 this year we're gonna
do it this year 2019 yeah and I can't
believe we're back we're gonna be back I
mean in 2019 of November that's right
we're gonna be back
[Music]
Daniel Radcliffe from miracle-workers is
a huge fan oh that's amazing
we love the Radcliffe yeah he should be
doing voices on our show you know what I
mean dude you're a good actor man he
should come in the writers room and hang
out for like a couple days and just like
hang out and like come up with a
character you could do and we'll just
that's a fun idea right and they've now
what you on the show thank you very much
that's really kind of you and I want
them to know that they don't have to
feel obliged because they were on camera
that would be crazy cool I would if they
have anyone thank you genuinely thank
you to the writers room you can be part
of it and then you can have a character
in the show that would be insane I would
love to do that because they said it it
means it's legally binding we have
footage of you you're all my witness
yeah okay then I will try and make this
happen
hi everyone is Charlie awesome news
apparently Rick and Morty is coming back
during November this year so we knew it
was gonna come back some times this year
but now it's finally confirmed if you
live through the production breaks that
they've had before between seasons then
you know that sometimes you think that
it's coming out a certain year and
sometimes it'll roll into the next one
because some big delay so it is nice to
finally get confirmation but apparently
Daniel Radcliffe is bucking to join the
show and Justin and Dan are really
excited about it so maybe we'll get some
Harry Potter during season 4 season 5 we
actually do have a lot of details about
what's going on during season four so
we'll break it down if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Rick and Morty videos of course
we'll do episode videos when it gets
here obviously that's not gonna start
till November but there'll be teasers
and they'll go to Comic Con they'll drop
an animatic during that probably in the
funny thing about all this you probably
realize is that mr. poopy buttholes
prophesy about having a big white Santa
Claus beard won't be all that wrong
because the episodes are in November the
Christmas shopping season there will
actually be Santa Claus paraphernalia
all over
place but if you're wondering why
they're suddenly showing us this now and
not waiting till later or why they
didn't do it earlier is because they're
in the middle of the network advertiser
upfront swear networks preview all their
content in episodes for people who buy
ads that you see running during the
episodes Rick and Morty is one of
Turner's biggest properties right now so
of course they're gonna be there so
they've made this special little teaser
the season four teaser to show at the
upfront Stu advertisers and then just
posted it online for us I know you're
big follow-up question is is why are
they starting the season in November
instead of starting it in July like
they've done for season two in season
three even though there was a big break
between season 2 and season 3 and now
there's another big break between season
3 and season 4 each of the last couple
of seasons has aired during the summer
season one actually started in December
so it's not totally unusual for them to
air Rick and Morty episodes at the end
of the year but a lot of this will
depend on how many episodes happen
during season four if it's ten episodes
or fourteen episodes which they haven't
said yet but the reason why it's not
coming till November instead of July
probably just because they're taking a
little bit longer to finish episodes
Mylo great conspiracy theory is also
that they're waiting to start the season
season four til they complete more
episodes as part of their big 70 episode
order so that they can guarantee that
there's no huge break between seasons
after season four on top of that
networks also earn more ad money per
episode during the holiday shopping
season in November is prime holiday
shopping season so from day one they air
episodes in November
Rick and Morty as a show will earn them
more money per episode than if they
aired episodes during the summer so from
a business perspective it's better for
them to air episodes then but also I
think it's mostly just to guarantee
their schedule moving forward so that we
don't have to wait a year between
episodes between season 4 and 5 but Dan
Harmon and Justin roiland also said that
that was one of the reasons why they
went for that big 70 episode renewal
order so that they could just roll
through those 70 episodes taking a
couple breaks in between so that it be
easier for them to get episodes out on a
more regular schedule so the really cool
thing that they might wind up doing is
is that whether or not season four is 10
or 14 episodes is that once they finish
airing those episodes maybe they'll
start season 5 during next summer
instead of waiting of
full year to air the next season so
don't be surprised is they try to cram
in all 70 of these episodes into five
seasons of 14 episodes apiece
because if you've listened to the
commentary for Morty's mind-blower
season 3 episode 8 they joke about how
originally their plan was to do 14
episodes during season 3 but a
production delay stopped them from doing
that this is the clip of them talking
about it we had this all planned out
this was gonna air this was gonna air
9th and then and then the actual
interdimensional cable 3 was gonna air
12th in a world where we had 14 and then
we would have done we've done you know
two more and I would have been that but
yeah we we had we had we had due to
numerous production snafus we had that
we had that we had to cut back so there
is some evidence backing up the idea
that they want to do 14 episodes per
season but we don't have any official
confirmation about what their plan is
for season 4 you also probably heard
them say that they were originally
planning on doing more teas mind blowers
as inter-dimensional cable 3 when it was
supposed to be 14 episodes but because
they decreased the number they turned it
into Morty's mind blowers and it wound
up being a great idea for an episode
that turned out great so hopefully
they'll do more teas mind blowers too in
a future season at some point but
earlier this season justin roiland also
then tweeted out this interdimensional
cable 3 shoutout so they are planning on
doing interdimensional cable 3 but the
biggest last progress update we got from
justin roiland was on a podcast that he
went on at the end of last year during
2018 and by that point they had actually
gotten a couple big animatics done
here's the clip of him talking about it
so uh Rick and Morty huge Rick and Morty
news the show was renewed big-time yeah
tell me about that so we got we got a we
got a big hefty order for more episodes
Oh tell me about how big was the order
um it was like another six season right
it's it's it was it's 70 episodes 70 and
we're in the middle of production on
this oh god I mean well the jury's out
on that one I mean hopefully not
hopefully not you know a crazy
long amount of time now you guys are
currently in production of the new
season right yeah and how is that going
it's great it's going good we've got
we've got really good we've got some
really good stuff you have episodes in
the can we have we have some animatics
in the can yeah like we I mean we're
shipping stuff is getting shipped or
about to be episodes are about to be
shipped for color animation but yeah
like we're we're we're moving along
Ethan and you're and got a good season
that's great yeah everyone's super gonna
be so small conspiracy theory I do think
that they'll have enough episodes to
start season four during the summer but
they'll just hold it till November like
I said because they can earn more money
when they aired the episodes then but
once we hit season four there will be no
more giant breaks between seasons and
some seasons will probably be pretty
close together so if you like have you
been waiting for some good news that's
actually some really good Rick and Morty
news but if you're wondering what all
these daniel radcliffe rick and morty
jokes are about there was just an
interview that he did a while ago on a
talk show where he said that rick and
morty was one of his favorite shows he
would love to be on it the only other
real big details they've given us about
how the story is going during season
four is the dynamic in the house is
gonna be more like it was the first two
seasons the family's back together Beth
and Jerry are back together they didn't
say how much they would be bickering or
what the state of their marriage would
be but I'm sure will be perfect
especially because Beth has realized
that she has the same potential for
intelligence that Rick does so
potentially she could be just as great
and terrible as him at some point in the
series that they really wanted to take
at that bar I'm not expecting them to
harp too much on the idea of whether or
not Beth as a clone whether or not she
decided to take off when Rick gave her
the opportunity or if she decided to say
every once in a while don't reference
something like that but also funny thing
to talk about old characters coming back
I know we're all wondering about
squatchy iced tea was recently talking
about his character from get schwifty
making it sound like he actually wanted
to be a part of the series
[Music]
whereas if you go back and you listen to
the commentary on that episode when it
was recorded
Dan Harmon thought that ice-t thought
that the episode was stupid so he
actually made fun of him just a little
bit so maybe in the past couple of years
he's warmed up to the series and he'll
come back in some way I think just
because Rick and Morty is so much more
popular now celebrities want to be a
part of it so they'll probably have some
cool guest stars during season 4 daniel
radcliffe apparently among them at the
beginning of the season it seems like
Morty and summer are still keen to have
their family back together
unmoored he's kind of come around on
Rick a little bit so he's not spending
all of his time trying to get summer to
realize how terrible he is they sort of
accepted a level of equilibrium because
of the deal that they make with Rick at
the end of the season the big standoff
they have where he says fine Jerry you
win you get my family so it's actually
probably useful to go back and re-watch
season 1 and season 2 just to get a feel
for the dynamic of what season 4 is
gonna be at least at the beginning
because obviously they don't want to do
the exact same thing but they did say
that it would continue to be a mixture
of one-off self-contained episodes and
then the bigger larger mythology
episodes like evil Morty The Citadel of
Rick's the Galactic government if
someone wants to reform that maybe they
can bring Tammy back for that and then
whatever the central conflict is going
to be within the family that usually
drives them across the season really
good example is during season three the
divorce was actually the a story the
main story evil Morty the Citadel the
Galactic government that was all
secondary be in c-level story stuff so
we should go without saying that I think
we're all expecting them to check back
in with the Citadel at least sometime
during the season even if there's no
direct confrontation with evil Morty
himself there's actually a lot of cool
stuff that's gonna be happening when
Rick and Morty is premiering so they're
launching the Disney Plus streaming
service they have a couple Avengers TV
shows in the Star Wars Mandalorian TV
show that's gonna start and The Witcher
TV show on Netflix is supposed to start
airing episodes in December it's gonna
be crazy awesome at the end of this year
so I will do Easter egg in episode
videos for all those TV shows but when
we get a little bit closer we get some
trailers then I'll start to make a plan
and let you guys know what's going on
while you wait for everything click here
for the game of Thrones season 8 finale
trailer and click here for my Avengers
endgame deleted scenes and alternate
ending video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome we'll
see
guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]